thoughts on that wincing gambits yeah I
I have high thoughts about it it's like
the out of like all the venomous
openings and chests it's very high up
there and it's also like even though
there's been some youtube comment there
content from from Jonathan it's still
pretty pretty unknown so when you have a
highly venomous opening that's also
super rare it's a great combo but the
issue is you need your opponent to kind
of cooperate so I've actually been
working a little bit off stream on
developing a rapper tour around like the
Nachman soon and there's a bunch of
different motors to get get the position
ooh playing an FM okay I'm close iye for
I'll play my my new kind of repertoire
hey it's not been some time what are the
odds my opponent has studied this
probably hasn't I'm taking time that's
nice to see this is my first I think I
had not even seen like once before but I
have not had this position okay takes Oh
Queen d5 so most of what I know in this
opening comes from Jonathan trance I can
suggest following on YouTube and like
objectively I think this position is
close to equal but it's way more fun to
play for white there's some crazy line
like Bishop here takes each six and then
just takes an 87 I think is the best
move I believe rook takes e4 I have a
whole chess base file like digging into
some of these lines I vaguely remember
this and then this and the great thing
oh I remember Queen d6 - pretty sure
Queen d6 here if they play c6 the great
thing about this opening is especially
if you're well prepared like black has
to consume so much time to not get
needed okay now I have to consume time
probably just Bishop g5 that's great to
live yeah nice time to be alive Bishop
g5 I had these moves to calculate that I
didn't see what to do after King g8 I
was looking at night f5 Queen f4 looks
very nice because the knight and queen
would be hanging and I would be pinned
hmm yeah each six is probably a good
move and now I'm 95 it looks so much fun
but where's a mate there's a cool idea
there's a really cool idea wow that's a
cool idea 95 kingi 896 I don't know if
it works but it looks really cool
96 double pin anything better you see a
cool move look for a cooler move no 96
it's so cool
so this this and this are pinned to the
Queen it is this and I take the knight
I'm still down a piece but blocks
under-developed blocks has everything on
the back rank except this Knight which
has attacked four times and pinned b6o
I'll give a take back that was a clear
Mouse slip b6 was a bit too deep for
anyone's understanding I could also just
torch her blah oh but my bishops
attacked okay
so the main issue is black might make a
queen
but I might mean it's such a fun opening
Wow
Queen I faith I have work Yates and
there's no be one cuz I take with check
and then when the Queen and the meantime
oh that's a move I thinking like Queen
g6 I also have rook d7 here no play rook
d7 I might just start eating pawns
always have to be aware of this like
pawn promotion shenanigans like Queenie
ate some move even Queen f6 is a good
move - OH
what to do it's not so simple anymore
in Queen c5 oh I could take my time -
okay
have to play quicker
I don't want to lose like my first real
not mincing gambit rook a fait it's
expected at f3 always playoff 3 Chuck
ooh
C 3 is coming or that okay so I have C 3
myself there we go oh but I still have
comp let's go kind of have to keen power
good move no hole that was a really bad
dream of ah I lost hey it's a raid
it's Jennifer you raiding with 117 Wow
I'm so sorry to all the people who had
so much high hopes for me it's still
going on YouTube
I was a fun opening I have to learn I've
to learn from my mistakes and then
become stronger also let's give a shout
out to Johnny for you thanks so much for
reading if you're just joining you
missed one of the coolest openings and
going to man I spell that right I think
I spelled it right thanks Jennifer yeah
this this opening it's gonna it's like
hard to describe it it's like Bitcoin in
2011 or 2010 there's gonna be a huge
boom and then people are gonna learn why
it's like it's meaty refuted
but actually like I was trying to refute
it with engine and it's it's not so easy
to refute so I'm sure they can
especially in this position I'm sure I
had something analysis board first of
all opening book oh this has happened in
one game let's see what happened that
game so Bishop e5 h 6o Bishop h4 so calm
and g5 looks kind of annoying let's
check the beach house now the base
um I'm conflicted rather just to turn on
sock fish I think I will and see see if
it spits out like an easy win it doesn't
oh oh it's confused I might need a
stronger version of stockfish let's go
back
so after c6 Oh
maybe so I had mentioned I didn't
mention during the game that I had some
idea of Queen H 5 + e5 maybe this was a
line Queen g6 looks so attractive though
combined with Bishop g5 okay I'm gonna
check my file it's the best way to do
this weight prep and then yeah I guess I
can show this so this is my like white
rapper torn chess piece now having some
gambit is here I've done like some brief
mmm what's the best way to do this
I'm just gonna make this window smaller
okay hopefully that's decent looking so
yeah like the the main line here is what
most people walk into ninety seven is
very playable yeah so this is my prep so
Queen h5g six between a five oh and then
queen g6 so I got my lines mixed up
where Queen d6 happens only in this
position and White's supposed to be
better apparently this is high powered
starfish it's still a very confusing
position so it wants to play g5 this
should be fine this is all mainline Wow
95 King g8 it was incredible
yeah this actually takes a lot more like
further analysis I might share this at
some point I'm still working on it
though I work in chess base because I'll
occasionally uses like Leela chest too
but at some point I might might turn
this into a me chess study anyway it's a
cool opening even even when black like
plays it correctly there's so much joy
which can be had from this opening so if
this goes on youtube you two people hope
you guys enjoyed that G cook gifting
subs things she cook you to people say
hi to G cook and everyone else in the
twitch chat and I'll see you in the
future